soldat ukrainien progresse dans cette
maison en ruines dans leurs mains le
drapeau jaune et bleu qu'ils accrochent
fièrement à la façade de l'édifice petit
à petit l'armée ukrainienne progresse un
peu plus loin elle revendique aussi la
prise du village de nescounet
le 10 juin le 7e bataillon arène de la
129e brigade à libérer le village de
nescounet
[Musique]
gloire à la nation morose ennemis
l'Ukraine avant tout
au total la contre-offensive ukrainienne
n'aurait permis aux autorités de
reprendre trois villages dans le blast
de
deniezkuchenet blago Daphné et macarifca
première avancées territoriales depuis
plusieurs mois samedi vous le dit merci
qui avait admis que son armée avait
commencé la contre-offensive tant
attendu ce dimanche il a salué les
efforts de ses soldats
je suis reconnaissant à nos soldats pour
cette journée à toutes nos brigades de
combat à chacune de nos unités au
groupement de force horticia et Tavria à
tous ceux qui se battent actuellement à
tous ceux qui sont en position à tous
ceux qui aident merci merci pour chaque
pas pour chaque combat pour chaque
occupant détruit
Moscou à ses annonces de son côté le
ministère russe de la Défense a assuré
image à l'appui avoir repoussé une
attaque contre un navire de guerus sans
mer Noire
au cours de la contre-attaque tous les
bateaux ont été détruits par le feu des
armes standard du navet russe à 300 km
au sud-est de Sébastopol il n'y a pas eu
de victimes le navire n'a subi aucun
dommage
loin du front l'Ukraine et la Russie ont
par ailleurs procédé à un échange de
prisonniers 95
ukrainiens et 94 russes ont ainsi pu
retrouver la liberté